hey guys today I'm going to talk about
possibility of the one shoe King Stannis
Baratheon being alive supported it
effects whereupon I'm going to tell you
my opinion about the same topic till now
standing / is deficient forces to
Winterfell and ordered them to prepare
for siege but only a few moments later
one of his generals said that there is
no need for siege since the Bolton army
was charging on them assembly decided to
fight Stannis on the open field at the
Bolton army that contains only the
Vulcan cavalry was charging at modest
forces of Stannis Baratheon's army the
outcome was clear Stannis and his men
are dead but just a Johnson on bravely
pulled his sword out against the enemy
cavalry Stannis did the same
he raised his sword with only one major
difference there was no friendly cavalry
to say Stannis surprisingly at the
battle was done as RAM this forces
heavily outnumbered and defeated
Stannis's army Stannis survived and on
top of all of that after he already
fought bravely throughout the whole
battle survived he also fought against
to both of soldiers in the end of the
battle while being visibly wounded and
still managed to kill both of them but
he suffered severe wound on his leg in
the process while Stannis decided to
rest by tree all of the sudden Brienne
of Tarth appeared in front of Stannis
and confronted him Brienne firstly
identified herself and asked him 'if use
blood magic to murder Renly Baratheon
which resulted that Stannis is
compassion Birbhum Brienne sentenced him
to death and beheaded him with a single
stroke or at least that is what we've
been told but let's get a few moments
back before Brienne apparently executed
Stannis she asks him if he has any last
words words that might have changed
Ben's decision words that might have
stayed Stannis from beheading
standing such as he fought Bolton's man
to his end with impossible odds refused
to perhaps back for his life which is
not surprising as this is Stannis
Baratheon his last words were go on do
your duty whereupon Brienne was stunned
for a few seconds which at first could
be described after being surprised over
Stannis his last words but as i rewatch
that scene those two seconds of Brienne
being stunned
could also be a result of her
reconsidering her decision reinstate
expression upon Stannis is last versus
priceless as
his last words not only the stance led
Brianne to think if her loyalty and
support toward Renly as rightful heir of
the Seven Kingdoms was right since then
this is the one true king the rightful
king of the Seven Kingdoms but also at
Brienne to think which her real Duty
actually is which was to watch over and
protect Sansa Stark which he failed upon
avenging Renly and upon missing sensor
lighting a candle Brienne was reminded
by Petyr Baelish about her failures as
he reminded her that she soared to
protect Renly but she failed she sought
to protect Catelyn Stark
she failed while Stannis reminded her of
two following failures so Brienne made
his last words as he said go on do your
duty
which of your seconds of her being
stunned surely representing her thinking
about what her duty really is as Sheen
that very moment failed it which was to
watch over Sansa scene ended with
Brienne angrily swinging her Valyrian
steel sword at the one true king but we
didn't see if Brienne of Tarth actually
killed him as we've never seen the
corpse the facts from the series and
from a scene in which Stannis supposedly
died harshly are going in favor of
Brienne reconsidering her decision and
obreon realizing that she made a mistake
is supporting Renly at the first place
and by leaving sense unwashed in order
to fulfill her order wahwah well Bryan
made a mistake by supporting Renly as
rightful king of the Seven Kingdoms
whereupon she also swore to avenge this
same false King's death by killing or
not killing Stannis either way she
broken nodes as by killing Stannis she
became the King's lair as Stannis was
the rightful king of the Seven Kingdoms
while by not killing Stannis she would
have broken a vow to avenge Renly's
death until season six aired I was
convinced the Stannis will reappear at
some point but with the conversation
between rules and Ramsay that took place
in the premiere episode of season six
image rules said to his bastard son
thanks to you the false King Stannis
Baratheon is dead
Verplank II asked him do you know who
struck the killing blow in order to
reward a man that killed Stannis which
most probably mean that rules and
remedies of Spanish corpse which means
that the one true king is most probably
dead
in conclusion Stannis Baratheon most
probably won't reappear in the upcoming
or in the last final season something
that I will miss
sure about if there are three seasons
left or at least the remaining two
seasons would contain usual ten episodes
per season instead of both seasons being
shortened and containing in total 13
episodes hope you guys enjoyed this
video incident please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]
[Music]
you